oh gosh this is a massive haul of
goodies some of these have a lot some
people have said to me I have been
wanting to unbox this stuff for quite a
while and I think you're hey why not
just take all of these goodies and
gadgets and unbox them at the same time
I guess we'll start from the top
this first thing that I got this is a
compact Wireless blood pressure monitor
what justine are you five hundred years
old that you need to monitor your blood
pressure maybe I am
don't judge me so recently I've started
getting into health which is something
that I probably should have gotten into
a very long time ago I feel like I go
through phases I think that's something
that everyone probably goes through but
I am going to try my absolute hardest to
not make this a phase and just make it a
part of my life so step one was to get a
scale which I got I got one of the Nokia
scales and it was like hey would you
like to Amazon you know me so well and
then it also said well since you're
buying that do you want to get a
thermometer with it and I said okay sure
if I'm investing in my health and in my
future it's a wise purchase let's open
up our first one I guess we'll go with
the thermometer oops I forgot to get a
thumbnail hold on got the shot oh here
it is it says right there that simple
tab full interesting anything else in
here probably directions those are gonna
be important although I think this is
probably quite simple the things that
look simple end up being the most
different all right well that's all
that's in there what's great is these
both will tie into the entire nokia
health ecosystem which also will connect
to the health app so all of that data
will be all contained inside of one
place so now I can take my temperature
my weight my heart rate and my blood
pressure all in one and I'll have a lot
of data for myself here it is I saw
these at CES along with the scale and I
said
I got it this looks big oh I gotta put
batteries in it does this come with
batteries I don't think it does so I
look forward to setting these up and
testing them out I'll definitely do a
follow-up video because I would love to
talk more about my health and fitness
journey I haven't been talking about it
mostly just because I feel like it's one
of those things that if you talk about
it too much online it just takes away
from actually doing it like just shut up
don't post about it just freakin do it I
used to think that accountability was
key so if I would talk about doing
something that you guys would keep me
accountable but that's actually the
stupidest thing that I think that I
could have ever really thought yeah it
is great to have other people be
accountable but honestly the only person
that you can count on is yourself
especially when it comes to doing
anything if you're not accountable for
yourself nobody else is gonna be either
but that being said let's move on to the
next thing
which is the complete opposite of health
and fitness it's gaming I have been a
huge Razer fan for such a long time and
they sent me and my sister a bunch of
goodies I already opened a few of them
they sent a really beautiful white mouse
and also a pink mouse I did open those
up a while ago because me and my sister
both needed a mouse when we were
traveling because they've been getting
into Fortnight lately
first up the little ears for your
headset I'm just not sure if it looks
cute on me I think I'm unboxing Jenna's
things as well here's the problem yeah
I'm definitely unboxing Jenna's I should
probably save some of these for her so
going along with oh my goodness dad
phones to match I wish that I didn't
really like the color pink as much
because I feel like it's such a
stereotypical thing for a girl to like
but guess what I don't care
I freaking like the color pink get over
it Oh
like and this is a really great color
pink - it's not like - hot pink more
like a salmony ish color in here
always my biggest fear is when I'm doing
unboxings and I'm just kind of like
going through opening of things and then
I throw something away and then I have
to dig through the trash later to find
it oh yeah who's the fairest of them all
please get long now okay so let's try
these on I was poking fun at these
earlier okay well they're crooked got
you gotta go over here you've gotta move
over this headset is surprisingly
comfortable I feel like the cat here is
just instantly make me a better person
better gamer probably not do I look good
I just wanna look good me and Jen are
definitely gonna be fighting over this
see she already claimed the white mouse
but this is a duel siding gaming mouse
and it's beautiful and white as well
oops microphone in the shot let's zoom
out a little so we can get a better shot
like razor just makes really nice things
this is super official Oh
oh my goodness this looks so good Wow
just out so when they say dual cider
they have two different textures so this
one is a little bit more smooth and this
one has a little bit more of a textured
feel to it so depending upon your
preference you've got both this is so
nice
oh it looks like a cutting board let's
just not tell Jenna that they sent two
of these
I'm like not strong enough to freaking
her with us what am I doing wrong the
pink and gray combination oh my god and
these stickers are holographic what also
dual sided it's got the pink accent
Razer logo right here this is gonna look
so good on my desk me and Jenna are
definitely gonna have some discussions
man I still can't believe these
holographic pink stickers - this is a
huge keyboard though wow this is massive
it's be great for streaming you guys
would be like sting you don't stream
there is something about typing on a
mechanical keyboard that is so
satisfying subscribe to my youtube
channel and don't forget to hit the bell
actually hit delete when I spelled
something wrong the weed health fresh it
looks okay so we also have this pink
water this looks like it's a little bit
smaller well I think I'm taking the pink
one whether Jenna likes it or not
although the white looks so great - she
did already take the white mouse so I
guess it's only fair so here's the wrist
guard here's the keyboard as you can see
the size comparison between the white
one and the pink the white is much
bigger and it's magnetic that's a nice
type okay let me show you guys all pink
set up any dads an access on my surface
to do Mouse you can call me basic and I
don't even freaking care there is a well
no that's pretty it's pretty accurate
I'll say there's a slight pink
inconsistency between the mouse and the
keyboard this looks like it's a little
bit more of a pale pink very very slight
I need to go put this in my desk
immediately oh I have one more thing
this is the final thing this is actually
pretty exciting so this is a stream deck
I am excited even though I'm not a huge
streamer I've seen so many other
streamers use this
I've definitely wanted to try it so
let's take a peek here it is so they
said to plug it in I don't see what
happens this basically lets you do a
bunch of presets very easily so if
you're streaming it's kind of like a
very mini little switchboard so you can
set up various actions to do oh no I
don't have a plug oh my gosh can you
guys see it it has my logo on it no way
can you see it I hope you guys can see
it let me zoom in look at that and it
matches everything cuz it it's like the
pink in the purple this is so awesome oh
my goodness I love it so much how cool
okay thank you so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this little mini
tech haul I guess it wasn't actually
that mini I've had some of these things
for a while so super said to finally
open it didn't bucks it and basically
now do a pink makeover in my office
stand for this to looks great
guess this means I don't have to start
streaming now if you guys are new here
make sure you subscribe also be sure to
hit the like button and most importantly
hit the bell that will notify you guys
when I post new videos also be sure to
follow me on Twitter because I also post
small or cut down videos of all of my
youtube videos they're spoiler alert
[Music]